fitton barracks Town Hall is being
displayed in a new light for a while at
least League draka or light dragon is
the title of a project by 15
international artists they combine
videos with live dance performances
at times it's hard to tell fact from
fiction thanks to the special video
mapping software involution in their
plots alright we had to work hard in the
space we can't change the space
according to our wishes I'll give you an
example the statue of Luther is just a
few meters in front of the town hall
this was quite a challenge how can you
project an image on the facade with this
huge statue in the middle League draka
alludes to the biblical characters Adam
and Eve in the fall of man by
Renaissance artist Lucas Cranach the
younger who's five hundredth birthday is
being celebrated this year chronic scene
here to the right worked on commissions
together with his famous father Lucas
Cranach the elder the snake was to
become the trademark of their workshop
in Vicksburg Lucas Cranach the younger
is best known for his portraits it's
striking how often reformer Martin
Luther appeared in his paintings Lucas
cut off the universe Thank You Lucas
Cranach the younger was always
overshadowed by his father Lucas Cranach
the elder and this year for the first
time he's really emerged from the
shadows his pictures gave the
Reformation a profile in the world
because he kept on portraying the
Reformers in his pictures the strong
motifs of Lucas Cranach the younger his
works have inspired artists through the
centuries his portrayal of Christ's
crucifixion for example Germany's Yosef
boys russian painter Marc Chagall and us
artist Keith Haring all drew on chronic
symbolism
as did pablo picasso and omri Matisse
fitting back artists ulrika Kirchner has
concentrated on Crocs portraits she's
created 11 works inspired by his
paintings and displayed them on the
outside of a shopping mall turning it
into a street gallery computed the
procedure is a technical one they're
like billboards but billboards of a
different kind ones designed to catch
the eye and get people thinking yawns oi
the light installation word up moves
chronixx former print workshop on Vinton
Berg's marketplace to center stage
chronic the younger took over the
running of the family business
the cyclic sash money funds what I found
very exciting and interesting was that
this building was chronic sprint
workshop and it was the age when book
printing started here in this region
started it it's very exciting to work
with the workshops equipment in
particular the tightwad the individual
letters returned and the night slim
boost on top of it modern-day artists
interpret a painter who was born five
hundred years ago in very diverse ways
with the Renaissance painter have
approved stinking they would search for
enough info it's my think he'd be
pleased definitely it's always nice to
have a specific context chronic has
always been explained inside out
everything's been recorded in detail
stinkers from alice exact and a clear to
work on but it's always good to have a
different perspective on the same topic
one that's a bit more flexible not so
set in stone elijah tyrannous english so
fastest so stuff one thing is for sure
wittenberg isn't likely to forget lucas
cranach the younger anytime soon events
to mark chronixx five hundredth birthday
continued until november